thank you very much hello good morning
and thanks for being here you could have
course picked other sessions but I'm
gonna have some fun talking about future
hashing yeah
so I'm John Lucca and there's mentioned
I'm a data scientist at Microsoft in
Azure cat as part of di lab that's
customer advisory service or team rather
go out to customers and build up
solutions for them with some machine
learning infused into it so what we're
going to be talking about today is
partly inspired by some of the work I've
done in the last year and a half or so I
cannot mention any customers
hopefully our legal department would not
come chasing after me for what I'm gonna
share with you but should be all good
and I recognize a few faces so I also do
some teaching general assembly I have my
own company to do that so if you've seen
it before hello again so we're going to
be talking about a few things I'll start
just with a very brief introduction or
what the problem is I have my one slide
of what supervised machine learning is
and then just briefly talk to you about
feature hashing the ideas some of them
are quite simple I find some of they're
a bit more complicated and I'll present
to you a use case which is an actual
project with the livered six months ago
so and then we'll close it by talking
about library support in Python and in
some other languages as well before we
begin I really should thank two people
Arata Markus are both in my team at
Microsoft and they both can introduce me
to teacher hashing and the obvious and
less obvious tricks that I'm going to
share with you today so thanks to them
if you're watching on YouTube and let's
start with some background so typically
in supervisor mail you have one big
matrix of predictors which we call X and
then you have a vector let's assume it's
just a single outcome which we call Y
and if you're doing stats
typically you have a lot more
observations then you have predictors
right and this is the kind of the
assumption of traditional stats
and then what machine learning is this
you want to find
best estimator of some statistic which
could be the average value for instance
that's not good that's back for instance
the average value of y given the values
for the predictors and then you build
that black box you input the predictors
and it spits out the prediction right
and for the sake of today we're going to
mostly be interested in linear model so
generalized linear models where you have
some function G which is typically
called link function and then you have
up here this X transpose sorry in this X
beta X is a matrix beat as a vector of
regression coefficients so that's the
linear part right that's the linear
predict and then by changing G you end
up with a linear regression if that's
the identity function you end up with
logistic regression if there's a sigma
inverse sigmoid function you end up with
a Poisson regression with some other
assumptions but the main problem is that
you want to find estimates for that
meter so that's what the problem is how
you go and find them is of course an
entirely different talk which I gave at
PI days along the last year so you can
go and look that up but that's that's
what there is to it now the issue with
that X is that very often you have
categorical features so you might have
continuous features and then for
whatever reason you decide to buckets
them age is a good one right we use age
buckets rather than using age directly
you might do this in linear models
because you assume that there's some
non-linearity and so you want to
discretize it then you have one not
encoding which is common for categorical
features and if you're doing NLP perhaps
a bit old school school NLP nowadays you
also have a bag of words representation
so we're going to talk about those two
next imagine you have a data frame with
your country and that's got the four
countries that form the the UK England
Wales Scotland and Northern Ireland then
suddenly from one column in your data
frame you end up with four columns you
would probably exclude one right
otherwise they're fully correlated but
you end up with four columns in your big
predictor matrix X now if you imagine
that country was actually all 200
countries in the world suddenly from one
you end up with 200 features that you
then need to train your model on and
this problem is even worse if you're
doing better words in this case you have
three sentences which I called document
this three ladies Ashley Barbara and
Carol do memorize what daylight like
because they'll be a test later
so Ashley loves cats and she likes dogs
Barbara hates cats I don't know how
that's possible but she loves dogs and
Carol loves both so then you clean this
up you know you took an eyes and you
make words lowercase and maybe you
removed the names and you have some stop
words and then you have out of the three
sentences you end up with five
predictors and of course this is a silly
small example but your dictionary
explodes pretty quickly given that
there's a lot of words in in human
languages so what's the problem with
that right the problem is that the
number of observations is fixed because
that's your data set so there's nothing
we can do about that but the number of
predictors that you're going to use the
number of features that are going to go
into your machine learning model depends
on the cardinality of the features if
you have a hundred words in your
language that you observe in your
documents then you're gonna have a
hundred well 99
columns let's say if you have a country
column that contains 200 distinct values
you're going to end up with 200 features
so that's big and why is this a problem
there's two problems the first one is
for online learning if you're training
imagine you have very large data sets
which is the case I'm gonna show you
later
you perhaps do not know how many words
are in your dictionary to start with or
perhaps you do not know how many unique
distinct categories you have for a
column so this requires you to do a
first pass on the data set to understand
how many there are and then you can
build up the dummy variables that way
and there's also I guessed is this more
for the statisticians amongst us when
the number of features becomes closer to
the number of of observations or
surpasses it then this breaks
traditional estimation in the
statistical sense so these are the
problems and you might be thinking to
yourself well I've heard of this before
right in the neural net
because the neural network has a lot of
inputs like that picture of a slightly
confused cat and each pixel becomes a
predictor in your model and maybe you
have RGB values or you know so that's
1024 pixels squared times 3 so there's a
lot of inputs then there's some magic a
high in the center and this picks out a
vector that predicts with 99% accuracy
that that's a picture of a cat right
another dog so this is similar because
you have a lot of inputs but it's
fundamentally different in the aspect of
sparsity and the difference is that in
something like my cats here I don't
really have a lot of zeros right I have
values that encode the three different
color channels or whatever if you
depending on how you do it of course but
I have a lot of values that are always
present if I have something like my
country example most of those values
will be zero so there's a lot of
sparsity and this happens a lot in fact
it happens in ads tech when you have
users clicking on ads on mobiles on
websites
it happens in e-commerce transactions
which is partly the example I'm going to
show you it happens in social networks
where you have a lot of interactions but
most of the time people do not really
interact if you think of Facebook you're
probably interact with a very small
proportion of the entire user base so
this is the problem and the idea is that
we should be able to find a smaller X
and you could use PCA right or SVD or
some other linear algebra trick but
they're not very efficient in terms of
how long it takes to compute and I'm
always thinking of that online learning
and I have a massive data set that I
need to go through I do not want to
spend a lot of time doing this the other
thing I do want is my number of features
to be fixed so I kind of know that the
model size will be however much I
specify and I want to preserve the
sparsity because this means I can
compress my data down right I can only
save the nonzero entries in my X matrix
which is good so can we do this if the
question and of course you're here so
the answer is yes and the answer is B
trash
just to recap before we move on problem
with categorical contextual features is
that the number of features depend on
the future cardinality and this is often
very large and kind of explodes
sometimes without you noticing too much
so we want this more efficient sparse
representation art so let's see the
trick so idea with feature ashing is
that you start with country equal to
England let's say which was the first
observation then you pass it to some
magical H function which will be the
topic of much discussion in this part of
the talk so you give it this country
equal to England and it spits out a
number how it does that we'll chat about
in a second and then that number is a
bit too big to use so we need to reduce
it down because remember we want a fixed
model size so we want the index to be
let's say we want a hundred predictors
right so we can take modular 100 and
that gets us 11 this is all that feature
ashing is of course there's a lot behind
it just to visualize what happens you
have again that data frame with country
equal to england I've computed here the
using that same function which we'll
talk about in a second I've computes
different indices and of course you have
Scotland appears twice and it gets
mapped to the same index right which is
what you would expect and then over here
you get your sparse X matrix and it has
100 columns right but I'm only showing
you the nonzero ones so you can see the
dummy variables effectively just
scrambled around so you might be asking
is always the same as doing dummy
variables right just in a different
order but there's more to this before we
move on it's time and space efficient I
timed it with the magic time it and it
takes roughly half a millisecond to hash
one value so I can do this very quickly
it is also quite space efficient because
of course I don't need to save that
whole row of a hundred values I can just
save the position of the one that's in
there
and the other thing which I'm going to
Luder just now but we'll discuss later
is that I can compute it on the fly
right I don't need to store anything in
memory
really please fixed still sparse so it's
beautiful
now that hash function is interesting
and something we need to chat about so H
in the theory Maps any integer input so
you can give it anything at all and it
will give you back as output an integer
in some range for instance a 32-bit
integer which is what the function I'm
using thus it's two properties which are
quite important the first one is that it
should be uniform so it should get any
let's say you're using 32-bit integers
it should get as after put any integer
out and you should also have this
avalanche effect so what happens here if
you go and look at the ASCII
representation of the character
lowercase a and the character lowercase
C they differ by just one bit but of
course the the hash function maps them
to two entirely different values so this
is the important property they need to
be as random as possible basically so if
you want to do this in in Python there's
a couple of packages and there's one
called pi hash which interprets or has a
lot more hash functions m m h304ee72
I to compute my H I pass through this
hash function my string some seed which
of course you should set to 42 and
signed equal to false that will come up
later then I do my modular right and I
get out my 11 and then you can imagine
doing a dot apply or something like that
to do it automatically in to a panda's
data frame or something similar so we'll
go through it line by line the first one
is actually line three where I'm not
doing anything but I said a moment ago
that H maps any integer to another
integer in some range right and of
course I'm passing it a string which is
a bit mysterious
of course any string can be represented
and he's in fact represented as a very
large integer in memory in our computers
the only thing I'm going to point out
because I was bit by this so this
happened to me not with German which is
my example here but with some other
Eastern language strings and human
languages in general are messy very
messy you have two ways of representing
the word shown in German the first one
is by using the this character which is
the letter L with an umlaut on top and
the second one is to actually have the
letter O followed by a combination
character for DM Luxor the two dots at
the top when you print them out they
look the same but they're not the same
if you try and compare them which makes
it quite complicated because the bit
representation of the two is different
and so they hash the different values
even though they are the same this gets
much more complicated when you deal with
non Latin script there are some weird
rules in there which I'm not bore you
with but the solution to this is to
normalize most times this is enough it's
a bit magical but the idea of using this
normalized functions from unicode data
which is part of the standard library is
to just convert everything in this case
to the second representation and then
you're happy we know that everything is
that looks the same on screen is
actually the same in memory so this was
more of an aside because I've been
burned by it before the second aside is
that we had that module operator which
reduces the size noun from integer 32
right just very large numbers
potentially down to what we want and I
said well let's create a hundreds of
them a hundred buckets now if the hash
sizes are power too and why not right
you can do much better so if you use the
modulo operator and you time it with 128
then you get 81 point 3 nanoseconds if
you use the end with the size minus 1
which is a kind of
trick for modulo power - then you get
down to 57 90 seconds so just save you
30% of computation time with one way a
trick so it's it's quite amazing that
this should work and this is again
something that if you look at it at the
timings right its nanoseconds who cares
but then imagine doing this millions and
millions of times
so all adds up funnily what happens if I
have my function up there right I've
just created that H function sometimes
you will simply because you're reducing
down so your bucketing everything
together you get that if country is
equal to United Kingdom or country is
equal to Bulgaria you will get the same
index out and this is known as a
collision so when this happens well of
course this happens more if that 127 is
smaller because you're hashing a very
large space down to something smaller so
you could always increase that but this
will mean you have a larger model and
there is some impact on statistical
performance if you imagine that number 6
will be the seventh coefficient in your
model and that will represent both the
UK and Bulgaria together and maybe
depending on what you're trying to do
this makes absolutely no sense right so
this is a possibility now interestingly
enough there's a lot of studies that
have been done on this and published
papers on how much does this impact the
performance of the model the statistical
performance right and the answer is not
very much surprisingly so you can have
quite a large amount of collisions up to
50 percent and the performance doesn't
drop too much it drops you know a couple
of percentage points so it's not too bad
the other thing that you lose though is
the interpretability because the nice
thing with linear models is that you
have a coefficient for the UK and you
can look at it and you can say well this
is the effect when countries equal to
United Kingdom in this case you can't
because that coefficient in position or
in index six corresponds to two or in
fact it corresponds I picked that one
going through a list of countries
there's I think another seven countries
that hash to the same so it's a large
bucket that contain
a collection of things right now one
trick that you can use to avoid this is
to use yet another function which in
most papers is is called C so I've kept
with the notation and what you do here
is a bit strange so it's the same as
before but now this signed I've switched
to true so this returns to me a signed
integer that's 32-bit in two's
complement representation and the first
one is the sign and that's also random
so what I'm going to do I'm going to
return what we saw before in absolute
value then I pass it to modular 128 with
my trick which gives me 6 and the second
bit that you see over here just checks
the sign so if it's positive then this
will be true times 2 minus 1 returns 1
if this is negative this is 0 times 2 is
0 minus 1 is minus 1 so this returns to
me a plus 1 or minus 1 to indicate
whether I should add or subtract to the
bucket so if you do this often enough
with a lot of observations on average
you're gonna get some of them will be
positive some of them will be negative
they will cancel out in expectation and
this will see in my example so that
collisions do not add up in a sense but
they cancel each other out statistically
is perhaps a better idea so you can
think of h in two ways the more
mathematical way i guess is in maps any
integer input and anything in a computer
relays and integer writes onto another
integer in some range 32-bit 64-bit
doesn't really matter
oh if you're thinking more as a computer
scientist you can think that what h does
is it looks at the bits it scrambles
them up but in a fashion that's
deterministic so it's reproducible and
then produces a bitmap which is fixed
length so you go from very large
potentially very long pieces of text
down to something which is say an
integer between 1 and 0 and 127
the other thing I wanted to point out
again is that really the impact of
collisions is not too large and we've
done some experience in this with
customer data and we kind of see the
same that's published you can go up to
two or three collisions per bucket and
that seems to be fine so let's do an
example maybe this will make it clear
yeah they are Ashley Barbara and Carol
have returned and what I'm trying to do
is understand whether they like movies
and of course there's top movies and cap
movies and dog and dog and cat movies
like the Aristocats which also contains
dogs so I've got my I don't necessarily
agree with their choice of movies but
this is the data I was given so you've
you've got my user ABC for different
movies and then these two indicator
variables tell me whether the movie
contains cats and dogs and the rating is
what they rated the movie out of five
right it's a kind of IMDB esque example
so this is the data I get out and of
course if I were to create dummy
variables user expands into three writes
movie expands into four these two dummy
variables are the same the rating is our
wife is our outcome that gets excluded
out so what I'm going to do instead is
I'm going to apply my hash function to
this and if I do this you can still see
the structure right this is hash Lee
this is Barbara this is Carol you can
see the movies being repeated and then
some of them of course will end up in
different positions there are no
collisions just yet got my cats and dogs
variables and this becomes a huge huge
matrix with a hundred and twenty eight
columns which is mostly sparse and I've
got some plus ones and minus ones due to
that trick with the sign that I
presented to you a second ago so then I
start and I pass this to my model and
sorry for the slightly
are inspired formula that I find it easy
to think about the modern listens so
what I'm gonna say is the rating is a
linear function of the user the movie
whether the movie has cats some of the
movie has dogs so I'm trying to build
some sort of recommendation system right
and if you think about it for a second
that user so having one coefficient per
user tells me the average effect in a
sense this is this user tends to rate
movies irrespective of the movie roughly
people in five stars right then you have
a second effect for movie which is
irrespective of the user this movie
tends to get rated around four stars or
whatever it is and then you have some
more average effects for movie related
features like cats and dogs first one
let's say the second one is the same so
has cats and the coefficient for that
feature tells me in general what the
average rating for movies that have cats
in them is right and same thing for for
the dogs so there's no recommendation
it's not very nice or we can fix that we
can add some interaction terms so we
have the same thing we have the average
effective user the average effect of the
movies but now we also have a
coefficient for whether the user likes
movies that have cats in them probably
the user likes movies to have dogs in
them and now suddenly this becomes much
bigger because of the interaction terms
so when you have feature hashing is a
nice trick that you can apply so if you
have two hashes like let's say I want to
determine where I should put the
coefficient for hash Li and a movie
having cats in them I already know what
the hash value is it's two with a
negative sign and it's nine with a
positive sign so I can combine them
again this should have been centered
sorry I can combine them again this is
another hash function known as session
v1a I can reduce them down to MySpace
and then I can just take the product so
I can use yet another hash function to
determine what the bucket for that
coefficient should be and it happens to
be 81 with an
active sign so if I go back here I've
now created my interaction terms and in
this case you have hash Li rating a
movie with cats so I get an interaction
term between her user and - and the
movie having cats in line and that's the
81 that I just showed you then you can
do the same thing and redefine all your
variables like so now you do get a
collision right at some point this has
dogs which we had before clashes in the
same position 110 with where the barber
I think it is likes cats so the
coefficient for that interaction so
these two will cancel out one is
negative one is positive this is the
sign trick doing its magic and so they
will just be cancelled out and this
carries over in this representation over
that if it is into a model of course you
need a few more observations for this to
really work and you'll get out a model
where you can make recommendations from
so it's time and space efficient which
means you can do online learning
everything can be done on the fly right
you do not need to store anything at all
the indices can be computed on the fly
it preserves the sparsity which is not
necessarily what happens with let's say
pca decomposition of X and the other
thing I didn't mention but it's it's
quite cool is that it implicitly handles
missing data if you do not have a piece
of information then it hashes to zero
and it's just gone collisions are a
problem of course they don't impact
statistical performance too much but
they do so that's something you need to
consider and look into when you create a
model feature hashing and the other
issue I guess if you care about
interpret abilities how you're going to
reverse back so that coefficient doesn't
represent one particular feature it
represents potential an infinite number
of them right but at least in your
training data due to the collisions it
will represent a bunch of them together
and so will be affected by all of them
together
so let me show you how I use this in
recent times the scenario was a business
directory think Yelp but not in the
States and what they wanted to do is
that they wanted to improve the
relevance of search results you kind of
go there and say well I want an Italian
restaurant in central London and it will
spit out a number of results from an
elastic search instance they also wanted
to personalize because maybe I looked
for Italian restaurants and I really
like cheap Italian restaurants right or
upscale Italian restaurants and so you
want to rerun the results to be more
relevant to the query but also to the
user so can break this down into two the
relevance really means you want to
optimize the click-through rate so if I
look for Italian restaurants and there's
a French restaurant no one in the
results no one should click on that so I
should bubble up the Italian restaurants
at the top but I also want to
personalize so as I said if I've
previously contacted or looked at cheap
Italian restaurants then maybe you
should recommend to me the same or if I
look up a French restaurant then you
should take into account the fact that I
don't go for the most expensive
restaurants normally and not show them
to me at the top of the search results
so this is the kind of data that we had
some user as the query and then there's
several businesses right one of them is
the famous French restaurant is the
second one so no one clicks on that and
you have some clicks this was roughly
350 million observations in that big X
matrix and you have a lot of attributes
for the businesses when they're open
what Kazim they serve this is not just
restaurants by the way so you have a lot
of different and sparse attributes out
so this is the model and it's the same
as before right there's the average
effect for the user how much do they
click in general for the query how
frequently is that query then can we
answer it for the restaurants in this
case and for the business same story
then you get the correction for the
relevance is this query appropriate for
the business so you would imagine that
if I look up Italian restaurant
and this is an Italian restaurant even
though I do not know that people click
on it and so I should be able to learn
that that's a relevant result for my
query and opposite for the French one
and finally for the user is the same
story if a user clicks on things let's
say have a price range of low then we're
going to learn that that's what they
like so you get personalization and you
get rerun King for relevance pretty much
automatically this was with a very large
hash size in the end roughly eight and a
half million coefficients so this run on
spark ml for a while as a regular
largest aggression with an elastic net
it runs for a few hours and then you get
out your model and can make
recommendations out of it works
incredibly well based on the train test
splits we estimated around the 5 percent
increase in click-through rate and we
got roughly 10 percent in a/b testing so
this worked pretty well overall the
customer was very pleased so that was
good and more recent project used
something very similar for news
recommendation which again you can
decompose into do they like sports news
and all sorts of things and that we're
seeing similar results with with that as
well last thing I want to chat about is
how do you do it very briefly and the
reference implementation is in a
software called bobble rabbit VW it's in
C++ but you've got Python bindings also
due to one of my colleagues actually you
can do linear logistic process on
regression you can create instructions
on the fly it's very fast and you can
scale it up it processes a few million
observations per second so you can train
huge models with this some support in
scikit-learn
learn not too much there's a feature
hasha there's a hashing vectorizer for
text transformation it kind of does the
same as count vectorizer but with the
hashing trick included there's no
interactions at present and this may be
something I will be working on next and
in Apache spark you get some support
there's some PI spark transformers that
I have written for the project I talked
to you about those are on github and we
also we're also currently working on
bindings to Apple Babbitt so those are
coming soon to FML spark which is the
mattress with machine learning library
for spark and I've included links to all
of this on the github page for this
presentation you can go so to conclude
it's great especially if you have a lot
of data and you want to do online
training don't have to do online
training of course with you know we've
done this with spark and it works just
as well it really works well when you
have high cardinality features that
would explode typically right they would
become huge matrices of of predictors
and it works even better if you have
interactions of course you could decide
to not use linear models you could use
an SVM you can use any any sort of thing
but if you're doing interactions and
whatnot and also the online training
you're somewhat limited in the type of
models you can use so that was it for me
thank you very much and if you want to
keep in touch please do
[Applause]
I should add whilst to get the mic there
you'll find the slides and some links on
my github as well and babbling them for
the page so you can find all of that
stuff hi thanks for the talk I was
wondering if you experimented around say
performance of using hashing for
categorical variables or there's another
technique an entity embeddings where you
where you learn embeddings fix
dimensional representations together
with the model end to end I guess that
would apply more to neural networks have
you done any experiments with that we
have for that particular project in
particular both as you as you mentioned
just training embedding and end-to-end
and also train and embedding and use the
resulting vectors as features in the
bigger model I've the performance is is
alright I still find that VW is much
faster and you can build features pretty
much on the fly so that the memory usage
is effectively zero ok thank you hi
thanks for the talk is is that approach
something that could be or should be
easily integrated into the existing
gradient boosting libraries where you
don't actually need to go through the
one hot step excellent question
I have experimented with this kind of
approach and then either random forests
of gradient boosted trees and in fact it
wasn't for this particular problem at
least it wasn't any better than the
logistic regression with the
interactions I would hope and imagine
that if you didn't use interactions
maybe a tree based model would be able
to learn them so you could definitely
use the same approach just to kind of
bounce the the size of your X matrix but
I've not really seen great results out
of that
thank you for the talk and quick
question about sign bit because in many
libraries like in scikit-learn you can
use it or you can disable it do you
think it's a good idea to like use the
sign or or do you have any like
guidelines when this signed hash Inc is
better than then without sign a long
discussion that this was the two guys
that I think had the start I think we W
does not use it and we tried both with
and without and there's very little
difference to be honest the statistician
in me likes the fact that the sign
interaction cancels out in expectations
so the statistician says yes and it
doesn't cost any more computation sir
all right that's thanks
[Applause]